not long ago this entire area was
Farmland now it's a case study for how
cruel the Chinese housing boom can be
many here struck a deal with a developer
their land in exchange for new homes in
the high rises sprouting up eight years
later the homes aren't finished the
people here still stranded
thriving community in the village of
dawang Zhong but it exists in the
shadows of what they were promised some
including the elderly have shelter in
this temporary accommodation
it's here we meet Wong Fong and her
mother their old house is long
demolished she's now searching for work
and struggling to get by she needs the
home she's owed so it's a really long
time
um
she showed us inside the small space her
mother now lives
it's damp and full of rats she explains
significantly worse than what they gave
up
outside the remnants of ripped up lives
are everywhere across China developers
have come close to collapse leaving
people to pick up the pieces many like
this old lady now face soaring rent as
they wait she didn't have these
outgoings before her home was demolished
now she has to litter pick to make ends
meetings
foreign
the government has intervened with a
huge financial package to help restart
suspended activity but many here and
elsewhere believe just a few workers are
sent to keep up appearances we saw just
a handful
there aren't the most striking signs all
over this city of just how flawed the
Relentless model of borrowing and
building can be look here the money has
simply run out and the reality is that
the Chinese housing market for so long a
driver of growth is now a real liability
but unbelievably people are still
investing such as the obsession with
property here this man works for a
developer building another block just
Round the Corner he didn't want to show
his face how hot what current you and I
are cameras
[Music]
um
that relaxing will ease the short-term
pain but in the long term it makes boom
and bust more likely there is a systemic
problem here and it's people who are
paying for it Helena Smith Sky News
injenjo